Obviously, so many things about the show
that I feel people right
now are hungry for,
for example, during this COVID crisis,
nobody's been dressing up.
And I think, obviously the show is
really entertaining in so many ways,
but part of the show is
you all look so beautiful
and you're dressed so nicely
and everyone watching it
is wearing sweatpants.
Yes.
And T shirts.
Including me.
Including you.
In fact, I'm wearing
sweat pants right now.
(Conan laughing)
So basically, from the waste up you are,
there you go.
Yes, yes!
Yeah, I know.
I won't show you what I'm wearing,
'cause yeah, it's not good.
(both laughing)
I'm wearing very short shorts.
I believe it.
Not a good look.
Is there any chance,
because I've watched the show with my wife
and it's very interesting
because my wife and I watch the show
and we watch it in the main room.
We have two children
and they're teenagers,
but on the younger side of
being of being teenagers,
and they wander in and out.
So we love the show, but we were worried
about, we can't let them walking through
if there's an intense scene.
And then someone told us
the exact episode.
There's an episode that everyone,
that if there's kids around.
Oh yes, episode.
Is it six?
Yeah, I mean, yeah.
It's quite easy to remember,
actually, isn't it, as well.
Episode six.
Yeah, episode six is the danger
red light hazard warning.
No, I couldn't handle it.
I fainted twice.
(both laughing)
They took me to the hospital.
But it was fantastic, it was great,
but I just kept, they brought
me around with smelling salts.
But it was nice that the word is out.
Now first of all, that works both ways.
If there are people who are
worried about their kids,
worried about maybe their
grandmother coming into the room,
you need to be a little
careful about episode six,
but also know it's going to drive people
to episode six, as well.
Yeah.
So with my family, 'cause I
watched it with my grandparents.
And with my family we
just skipped episode six.
It was just a no-go.
(Conan laughing)
There's a few before that, as well.
So I had to sort of sit by the remote
and fast forward the
bits before episode six
that are slightly on the
precarious side, as well.
You're there with the
remote pushing fast forward.
Ready to go.
And you probably know exactly
what's happening and then
(Conan making fast forward sounds)
and then stop.
I'm like, you don't need to see this bit.
Yeah, and suddenly there's
like a baby or something.
And you're like, trust me.
Yeah, I had to give them a down low
of everything that happened
in that episode six
so they were all caught up.
So yeah, I gave them a little like,
okay, so what happens is,
and skipped all the bad parts.